with one word you guys were used to
describe White Lotus season two Aubrey
I'll start with you uh
uh volcanic
what happened last night just been a
series of very bad decisions well what
do you hope fans because obviously this
is a different show than the first
season but there is a built-in audience
what do you want them to know about
season two of White Lotus I mean I guess
just to expect a different you know it's
it's different I think totally it's the
first season in some ways it still has
that kind of essential Mike White tone
about it it's still you know witty and
satirical of like certain sets in
society but it also is affected by the
feeling of the location its focus is
slightly different it's more about kind
of relationships I think in sexual
politics
um so
yeah um it's a new adventure flirting is
one of the pleasures of life you're 80
years old but the women I desire remain
young this season's Very sensual right
there's a lot of passion a little sexy
baby is Italy we're all obsessed with
White Lotus I'm sure you guys were too
so you get the call that you get to be
part of the second season Aubry what was
your reaction oh my gosh it was like
Willy Wonka all over again
um yeah I was like I got the golden
ticket right now that's how it felt it
felt like you know so I was so lucky I
felt so lucky I couldn't believe it I
was I was psyched will did you feel like
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory when
you got the role yeah I guess I just
assume there'd been some kind of mistake
but yeah no I was very surprised and
excited for sure well obviously your
characters are on vacation with Megan
and Theo it's like you sold their
company you got rich and now he's your
best friend are these the kind of people
who are gonna be hanging out with now
did you vote babe be honest I did
the night I want to know what kind of
fun did y'all have together shooting in
Sicily Aubry why what did they say uh
there were some dinners interesting
there's some wine interesting but you
know uh Murray said he was having a
vacation and then Sabrina said she was
having intimate dinners with Jennifer
Coolidge living her best life what was
the experience like for you guys over
there we I would say that's on par with
our experience I don't want to speak for
well but yeah we had a many we had many
dinners you know that's what you do in
Italy you know you eat you drink Iman
dramanja
um so that's what we did we would have a
lot of group dinners and family style
you know we really we we lived it up you
have to when you're there you have to
yeah you have to you know lean into the
culture there did you lean into it will
I mean you also got to work with Aubry
and hang out with her I think that's
pretty cool yeah and then we had a great
time and you know it being like an
ensemble cost like there was gaps in
filming
um where you know we could you know take
some time so yeah it was great Aubry I
heard that Mike wrote this part for you
I mean that's got to feel flattering
right I think he wrote it he wrote it
with me and mine don't say that I will
say that yes I've been friends with him
for a long time we've wanted to work
together for a while so it felt really
really really like exciting for me
because I I was just like I've been
waiting I was meeting you know waiting
for that moment it was cool because he
knows so much about me and I think he
was excited to use what he knew and then
create you know create something so then
let me ask you this when you read about
this character in the script was your
reaction were you still flattered I was
horribly offended um no I I loved it I
think Harper I love Harper I love that
character now that he's loaded you think
he regrets marrying such a dud what is
going on with you there's a reason they
invited us here I totally relate to her
you know she's she comes on really
strong and has this kind of like hard
you know outer shell and then she's kind
of got a really a real vulnerable side
to her and I feel I feel that I mean I
feel like uh with the White Lotus and
especially the characters in The White
Lotus there's a lot of layers to peel
back you know Jennifer Coolidge is back
right this season a goddess right
goddess Queen icon everything whenever I
stay at a White Lotus I always have a
memorable time always what was it like
to have that energy on that set yeah it
was like being in the presence of the of
the queen she's she's she is larger than
life she's the best she's hilarious but
and more than that she's kind she's a
generous soul and she really like
delivers on you know what you want her
to be she just yeah she exceeds
expectations she's someone like that
character though it's like she you know
what I mean like she's really turning
around and then I hear like from Sabrina
that she's throwing her a wrap party on
her last day on set we went to go
shopping together we had romantic
dinners me and her but like she
organized a party for me on my wrapping
day oh yeah I mean she's the sweetest
Soul well did you get to interact or
meet Jennifer on set at all yeah she was
around and like as Aubrey says she
really sort of over delivers on her
expectations but I I also found her to
be sort of yeah very interested in
people and kind of genuinely wanted to
know about the people around her which I
think is always a great quality now in
your own lives are you guys going on
vacations with other couples or friends
or is it would you do it with a partner
or solo like what do you prefer you know
what I don't I can't honestly think of
any vacation that I've ever done a
couple's vacation I don't think I've
ever done a couple's vacation before
it's a lot of pressure I've done like
group girls trips I've done solo trips
and then of course family trips and then
couples trips you know but which do you
prefer it's been a while
it depends on it depends on where I'm at
okay sometimes I feel like I really need
that like girl you know girl girl
vacation girl time with my girlfriends
um and I love that and then sometimes I
love going by myself it's fun to you
know just get out there I honestly
thought that watching your guys's
characters I don't know if I could go on
vacation with a couple like you would
make it honestly for real well how about
you has did the show kind of I don't
know change the way you going on
vacation yeah I think it hits upon like
a really sort of uh
something that's very true about
vacations is that people think of it as
like the kind of Escape that may like
they wanted to fix everything about
their life they want to get away from
all their problems but the problems kind
of follow you to where you are you're
still the people that you are when you
get there you know like in the case of
this season it's almost like the
vacation becomes a sort of Boiling Pot
in which all of everyone's issues like
have to be confronted you know because
of like being thrown into such a
difference rather than escaping from it
it's like well you have to dive head
first towards those problems but it's
always worth it for the pasta and wine
right yeah Italy's just so romantic
you're gonna die we're gonna have to
drag you out of here what's one word you
guys are used to describe White Lotus
volcanic
look at you on seek now what they're
working together next time we'll go one
two three Vlogs
I'll take it we nailed it
foreign